hey guys this is a personal video what
I'm gonna sit here on my bed and hang
out with you guys drink some coffee and
answer your questions about me so if you
don't have your coffee yet grab the
coffee pause the video but if you do
have your coffee let's continue all
right now there's a lot of questions but
a lot of the questions is also the same
kind of questions so instead of me just
typing and responding to each of you
also thought hey let me make a video
about it so I've written down a few
things let's see here so the first
question Daniel what is your height well
I always say 1.86
right but whenever I'm in a new model
agency they have to measure my height
and sometimes it's one eight seven one
eight six one nine seven one six so I
don't know I think I'm probably TP
hundreds in accurate one eight six point
five Daniel what accent is that to be
honest I don't know look I I grew up in
South Africa right but I was born in the
neighbor country called Namibia which is
a very very very small country my
parents moved to South Africa when I was
a kid my genes where am i from
well my surname is merits and
my family is basically from two
different countries some of it is from
Germany and some of it is from
Netherlands Dutch so my first language
is not English my first language is
Afrikaans which is very similar to Dutch
so if I go to Netherlands and speak slow
and if you guys over there speak slogan
I can understand what you're saying
so it sounds a little bit like this if I
want to say hey how are you guys doing
today then I say hey what kind of media
listen doc see that is my language but
ever since I finished school I went to
England and then I went to a few other
countries and I stayed in one apartment
for two or three months at a time right
in all these different countries and
when you do stay in those model
apartments you stay with models from all
over the world people from Russia
America even Asia it doesn't matter so
many different countries right and then
somewhere along the lines you pick up a
different accent so every time when I
came back to South Africa my friends and
family said Daniel you sound different
anyway so I didn't realize what is going
on with my accent I wish I had my strong
survive freaking accent still but I kind
of lost it so that's in shorts
that's my accent Daniel are you gay this
question is probably asked by a few guys
who just stumbled upon my channel or
some who never watched my model
lifestyle series where I show you my
personal life you know some videos on
style fitness and grooming are a lot of
theory right and so in my model
lifestyle series I actually show you the
reality of my life and where I live
those tips in real life so in that model
lifestyle series you will also see my
wife and I we've been married for nine
years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm not gay definitely not gay all
right what is what do we have here do
you wear contact lenses no I don't wear
contact lenses my eyes are like this
sometimes I changed a little bit of
color but they were like between blue
and grey ish thanks to my mom and dad
just have a little bit of coffee here
[Music]
all right um Daniel what is your weight
and some people also ask my fat
percentage
Oh my weight all right
so that always change all right some
countries like Asia right now I mean
Japan right so now I'm probably the
skinniest that I can be because in Japan
they want you to be skinny I'm not
understand happy with it but I have to
do it to get the jobs to pay the bills
right so right now my weight is are on
76 which is the lowest that I want to be
if I go to other countries like South
Africa and my home I'll bring it up to
around 81 82 with where I just get and
build more lean muscle mass and so it is
always between those two figures 76 and
let's say a tune if I did not do
modeling then I would probably want to
be around 86 87 yes a lot heavier all
right yeah the fat percentage fat
percentage is around 8% 9% always I
don't want it to go over 10 because then
you start to see the fat on the sides
these love handles and also you can't
see the abs clearly and another reason
that I don't go lower than that is
because if I am around 5 or Stephan 6 or
fat percentage then it is not so good
for my face because I lose a lot of fat
in the face and my eyes are very deep in
my head you know the eye sockets so if I
have less fat I start to look like I
have these dark circles under my eyes
and
I just look unhealthy alright that's why
I don't really go that low exists it
looks bad
alright next one where are we ah here we
go Daniel are you a Christian Oh for
some people this might be a touchy
subject but yes I am I am a Christian
I'm a reborn Christian I'm not a
traditional Christian where I'm just
saying hey I'm a Christian but because
my parents were Christian and I'm a
traditional Christian no I'm real reborn
Christian I'm not going to talk about
that so much on this channel because
this channel is only about your outward
appearance and certain psychological
things to help you with this life but
I'm gonna start a second channel pretty
soon where I'm gonna talk about my faith
and it's gonna be called the LLM
Christian life stuff
[Music]
now if you're curious coming over check
it out you're welcome it doesn't matter
if you are not a believer in you're not
a Christian or if you are a Hindu or a
Buddhist or Muslim or if you don't
believe in God if you're a theater
you're very welcome you guys have known
me for a while and I think sometimes we
judge it at each other based on just our
religion without trying to really know
each other and understand each other
so for me I love to have conversations
about faith about those deeper things
about life like what is the meaning of
life where do we really come from where
do we go when we die all those kind of
stuff for me is very very interesting
and if you're curious to what my core
values and beliefs are most welcome to
come and check it out whenever I started
guys has been awesome thank you for
having coffee with me you know there are
just some things in life that are so
awesome like coffee I mean my goodness
anyway
let's do this again if you have any
questions about things about me ask it
in the comment section down below and
I'll see if I can maybe make a second
video off this alright guys let's talk
soon
[Music]